je suis venu sans gilet jaune mais je
suis là pour faire la révolution la
révolution robotique qui vous soulagera
de tâches casting et je suis le cerveau
de de jean michel fourgous un robot pour
qu elle mais cette cérémonie de voeux
2010 9 à saint quentin en yvelines un
clin d'oeil aux futurs et à ce qu'il
réserve à l'agglomération au cours de
cette soirée son président jean michel
fourgous ainsi fait plusieurs annonces
transports éducation sécurité des
réalisations qui commençons à voir le
jour dans les prochains mois malgré un
contexte économique compliqué on
retiendra à la possibilité pour les
lycées de se doter de tablettes pour
remplacer les manuels de seconde et de
première
la mise en place d'un système de
location de vélos des tests de navettes
autonome ou encore une modernisation des
commissariats
ça concerne trois commissariats ce rugby
en cours je suis trappe celui
d'elancourt bien sûr avec une
organisation très différente beaucoup
les médias et la présidence de la région
d'apporter son soutien financier
notamment pour le doublement du pont de
la villedieu qui relie saint quentin en
yvelines à la vallée de chevreuse dans
les yvelines on sait bien que tout le
monde ne peut pas arriver au bureau en
transport en commun
et là c'est la passerelle de la
villedieu qui est un vrai point noir du
transport et qui sépare la ville
nouvelle de la vallée de chevreuse nous
avons les moyens de nos ambitions nous
avons les moyens de financer tout ça
sans augmenter vos impôts pour la
quatrième année consécutive mieux relier
ces deux parties du territoire yvelinois
peut être une façon de souligner une
volonté d'accueillir de nouvelles
communes au sein de l'agglomération
c'est vrai que la réussite de 50 ha nous
oblige à monter en communauté urbaine où
on n'aura plus accès aux moyens
européens aux moyens nationaux je crois
que nos élus sont d'accord maintenant
c'est un réglage voilà
fera pas avant les élections municipales
je suis demandeur mais je sens qu'il
faut quand même démocratiquement quand
même attendre les élections municipales
je pense
[Applaudissements]